reject nation we are going to watch
gravity falls today episode 15. thank
you so much for being here as always
full length watch along so you're
sticking with the time go for gravity
falls will be over at our patreon page
massive thanks to all who have joined to
become superjax showing your support if
you can't join our patreon page all i
ask then in return can you please leave
a like that helps us out in the
algorithm plentifully also subscribe
click that notification bell to get
notified when our next reaction for
gravity follows us up lastly then peeps
at prepper prepper peeps keep being
peeps you prepper peeps
they helped us out of doubt all right
let's do this
watch out gravity falls because at 110
degrees we're looking at the hottest day
of the summer gross
oh no no
no wax stands they just killed an animal
it's opening week at the gravity falls
pool gravity falls pool today punter
turned it quick to the car it's gonna be
oh
hey kids little help here
all right off to the pool
and remember to be on alert for random
wildfires wait what oh
disgusting
i hate the heat
i really hate it ah the pool sparkling
oasis of summer enchantment yeah nothing
like sitting in a moist tub with
strangers it's like the bus but what
that's not a bad point whoa whoa stop
the presses
who's that
hello
worders dude never leaves the pool
people say he's a mysterious loner
it's gross is it getting hot out here or
is it just that guy it's the hottest day
of the year mabel
new crush on some random guy that's her
character look at his little mustache
hairs you are clearly enamored
oh
yes where's the lifeguard i am the
lifeguard i make the rules sucker boosh
she's attacking me with water
plus i get the best seat in the house
yeah you do
[Laughter]
so hey you want to go check more water
balloons or uncle stan i'd love to but i
got to spend the day doing tryouts we're
looking for a new assistant lifeguard
now's your chance
what if i was assistant lifeguard that
would be so much fun you're totally in
dude
you just have to check in with my boss
first mr pool check your boss
[Music]
[Laughter]
wow oh my gosh how crazy bumping into
you here even though you don't know each
other
how long have you been underwater that
doesn't matter
and your hair is beautiful no no it has
silly tangles oh so hey you want to go
dry off maybe hit the snack bar or i
i'm afraid i cannot for i have a
terrible secret
no
spf 100 good i like you
but this isn't an easy job it's anarchy
out there
[Music]
i think i can handle it can you handle
this
whoa do you think you have what it takes
boy do you
sure i guess
welcome to the deep end son sorry
oh this is happening you can swim right
just the right amount of sun and shade
and pointed away from where old man
mcgucket lotions himself
live your best life mcgucket i just
can't believe it wasn't already taken
and now to sit on it thereby claiming it
as my own
oh no
first serve
i'll first serve you
puja
no
hey wendy i got the job sweet want to go
abuse our power but what if pool check
catches us he seems emotionally unstable
pool jail ain't so bad as long as you
don't wind up in solitary
it's the knights that are the hardest oh
god
i brought you a sandwich oh oh yeah
what i like
sandwiches secrets share your secret
beautiful stranger that wet sandwich
does look delicious but you must never
tell another living soul my terrible
secret you have to stay away from me
because i am a merman
whoa
you never noticed that underwater people
yeah geez your voice is so deep and
masculine how old are you i am 12 years
old merman's voices changed when we were
like three and you're already getting a
mustache there are some who call me
[Music]
mondo what's a guy like you doing in a
public pool the cargo was headed for
gravity falls yeah
using all my strength i tried to escape
back home well but it was not to be ha
ha
oh no
[Music]
i would have died of dehydration hey
it's kind of your thing yeah that's
exactly what happened to me
continue leaking
i don't care that you're a merman you're
like the coolest guy i've ever met i
have never met another human like you
would you care to join me in a game of
the marco polo oh yes
yes
you're covering my gills oh no
weird it's a step up from those gnomes
you dated in the first episode but i
can't touch him or the pool patrol will
throw me in pool jail
[Music]
yes yes burn the child
you must free us the inflatable pool
duck revolution is at hand
[Laughter]
do not touch
have a good night son
lock up the supplies for me
you tonight sure where want to go for a
walk
merman i am a merman oh right then i'll
be back tonight
that's nice here i am kicking dipper in
his legs he couldn't move his legs after
that can you imagine not having legs
let's skip this part i'm here with my
whole family kickboxing
i too used to have a family once back in
the ocean
oh
escaping this pool required a plan that
was bold and daring
[Music]
[Applause]
this is it mabel first kiss moment here
we come just go for it
what are you doing with your mouth me
nothing this i was just eating some sour
candy
can i have some candy no
dude with this job you and me are gonna
be having fun all summer all summer oh
you gave me your word that you would
respect the sacred rules oh god
pool check are you crying that's not
important oh no some maniac broke into
the supply closet last night and
destroyed our one and only pool skimmer
i want you on a stakeout if one more
supply gets taken
armando are you okay family isn't it are
you thinking about them
oh freeze
grunkle stan i uh i'm sleepwalking also
now i'm sleep talking nice hat by the
way you you're the one destroying pool
supplies what no my crime is a lot
better than that i'm gonna get that seat
and be ready in the morning
ah
are you ready to see your family yes but
how can i a merman possibly escape okay
my original plan was to tape together a
bunch of fish sticks to make you a
prosthetic pair of people legs yes but
then i realized i could just transport
you in this cooler
[Laughter]
rubble's there that cooler just clear
its throat don't be silly there
certainly isn't a merman in there if
that's what you're implying hey look
wendy in a bikini really at night at
night
go mabel go
we can't all be saved
oh my poor kid hand over the pool
supplies in the name of pool
hey that's a badge of honor
whoa did i shoot this one in 3d
[Music]
i think someone just sped by her
probably just a dream
with you every day is a dream so they're
gay right they are lovers absolutely no
no
[Music]
oh no
hola
whoa
way to bury the lead mabel dipper
marmando the merman he's a merman nice
to meet you also i think i am dying
what no you're necesito
oh no armando dipper you're a lifeguard
give him cpr put him in the frickin
water lake
[Music]
oh god
oh god
i hate this
way to go
the
disney
[Applause]
kiss her don't know what it's like to
fall for someone even though you know in
your heart that it'll probably never
work out but you do anything for that
person
golly
give mermando the mega he's making
sacrifices for your ass well marmando i
guess this is it not quite
this is
yeah
that's what i'm talking hey that's gross
you just kissed him too you did the
right thing dipper yeah yeah
oh wait wait one last thing
[Music]
freemondo it's my fault sir i'm sorry i
got in too deep
and over the whistle boy
[Applause]
[Music]
oh no i just got fired what really yeah
i guess pull check found out i was
taking too many snacks how many
hey wanna go break rules somewhere else
of course she meant he gets to have a
win in the end
message in a bottle mabel i am home with
my family and i am very happy our first
kiss will always hold a place in my
heart technically hearts as a merman i
have like 17 hearts
horrifying but true more bottles on the
way
perhaps i predicted your plan and go to
the entire chair with glue last night
enjoy your chair
kids
[Music]
it's okay man
oh no oh no
[Music]
[Laughter]
hang in there buddy
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
no
oh
poor guy one out for that guy for
solitary that's my favorite credits one
so far damn this is a story about how a
man with a missing tooth
gets women
that long luscious hair
i wish i knew a guy like that yeah
guy with no legs
i do know several paraplegics
i have a there have a certain category
of contacts
[Laughter]
it's
yup
special special list of handicaps
any any moment in time when i need to
look good in public
hang out with them
guys could you all show up and flank me
make me look like a saint i'm a good
person oh you know
um yeah that was fun that's very fun not
spooky not scary i'm still mystical not
skeletons not skeletons
um this one had a lot of heart
it did it was a heartfelt once summer
love right here is what this one was man
relatable heat stories
yeah i hate the heat so much yeah never
go to like a public pool people go like
the ymcas out here who never do that
it's gross you don't want to swim around
with a bunch of people still wearing
their t-shirts i barely go to the pool
over here
yeah yeah you do have a pool
complex
you never know
do the democratic thing of like oh okay
you guys are here so either i'll just
stay in this one corner i'll come back
in a few hours and try again people
don't care it's such annoying as kids
nah kids don't care about anything
um so we had
mabel with the mermaid label merman
mabel with the merman inspired by john
humphrey over there right
sexalicious thank you first kiss was
with the merman
was it
i had a gay kiss in here yeah
you don't see that much in disney no
unless it's like way in the background
you really gotta look for it i don't
know
well i'm doing a kids show of all things
too well yeah well i mean parameter of
well it's not really a man it's a
mermaid and it's not really because he's
trying to like resuscitate him but you
know it can't be for all intents
purposes it's lips on lip it's action
it's funny this is the second
tv show we watched today with that kind
of gagging it's a
same-gendered uh oxygenation sequence
but you know what it really is it's
romance it's romance the joke of the of
the photo was that they're kissing um
yeah of course it counts it counts
bob iger at the time
fuming in his seat when they submitted
this episode
got one note back a single note papa
make those boys kiss
but i thought i liked their their little
romantic entanglement it's like lady in
the water and from m night shyamalan but
better and funnier better and more
enjoyable all around yeah
yeah and uh mr pull check man that guy
was was my hero this episode yeah i like
the extreme humor a lot yes like they
like the aggressive humor in this one
and the physical humor that comes along
with that it's like his
veins are always popping he's always got
the most intense look
that when when gideon uh was in grunkle
sanchez
instantly instantly resorts to like
screaming at the top of his lungs so
this is really funny to me
i do i do appreciate
the right placement i don't like it when
it's like the the overall tone but the
right placement of some extreme yelling
based humor
choice for for me this is a good episode
for that and they both have to have wins
chaos is saying dipper sacrifice
something
for someone else this is the first time
that his sacrifice cosmically paid off
yeah
you know it's like he did the right
thing and then the power is the beer
like with fire wendy i could do a horror
movie about a pool they absolutely could
just thinking about them and watching it
mm-hmm they've seen oculus sex bring
this from you up today you see oculus
yeah uh the evil mirror thing yeah evil
objects
yeah something about that plus you know
pool reflects you you can do all kinds
of like mind-bendery stuff too mine
would just be about a slow build of not
getting in that pool
and then they get in the pool they die
immediately
just like a blender it's just
disintegrated on the spot yeah all that
build up for a crazy 30 second climax
yeah
and there are lots of employees you
could make the pool scary i mean you
know there are so many uh instruments
there's just the body of water that it
is there's the solitary confinement
drain what does the pool mean what is
the pool's purpose reflection of the
pool no one knows where the pool comes
from or where the water came from
that's not chlorine what's in the water
i don't know
how does it stay so clean all the time
have you ever noticed
you never see anyone in the deep end
not even leaves scattered across the
surface maybe we shouldn't make one
i am already writing this group in my
head
it's gonna be just as successful as this
lady in the water
yes so we have that um
i'm surprised you know
that we never saw a dipper uh
yeah dipper
go go
gaga
gaga
uh what's her name hannah wendy wendy
never saw
gaga for wendy when she's
in her she's practically butt in her
yes
in her string bikini
in her in her one piece very revealing
yeah man
hey they said they had that one joke of
like why was wendy and a bikini
and uh i love uh
his age i would be like oh no don't look
yeah yeah i'm gonna be like oh god i
can't don't don't put your eyes out oh
no i'm a pervert yeah
they will zero me out and they will they
will embarrass me in front of everybody
call me out
yeah
dipper hey i mean for as uncool as he
often plays around wendy he played a
pretty cool this episode surprisingly
yeah
fun summer love
the pool the pool
the pool movie could work you'd be set
in a different era okay like when less
people had pools in their backyards and
[ __ ] yeah where it's like you had to go
to some gymnasium where they would open
up the floor well it could take place
during like a massive heat wave
you know where it's like you have to go
worst heat wave on record and then like
in their homes like the ac stops working
and stuff
and the water
don't go in the water it's so hot that
all the faucet water just comes out
boiling so like the pool is the last
resort
there is something
to do yeah dude i mean like
i was like massive heat wave everyone is
tempted to go in the pool but there's
something messed up
well that was this is my copy of right
yes yes yes this is a monetized video
yes and this is doc document of the
pitch i'm riding my pool moving
you can check the door
take the pool idea yeah yeah no pitch a
lot of random movie ideas here i'm doing
the movie man it could work it could be
like a cool like like a little more
gritty than a goosebumps but it's kind
of got that sort of like you know uh
twilight zoney kind of setup there plus
you can make it something that's spooky
for kids and spooky for adults i mean
you could do like way you're like full
out okay you could either do elevated
horror or you could do like 1408 horror
that's the key where like
[Laughter]
a lot less people around
ah you could even do that
full hotel but it's closed it's forced
it away from the pool that's what it is
the hotel is abandoned and yet somehow
the pool is crowded sequel to 1408 john
cusack really wants to try that pool
no matter how much people are
checked into this hotel partly to try
the pool
and just want to write about murder or
whatever his character died or however
stephen king character is a writer
yeah there's something to be said there
they go in the pool to go to like that
because it could be a temptation
absolutely especially during a heat wave
it's one of the only places of a respite
it's like you know just have like a
shark or something but if it's 1408 some
of the gas see a shark at some point in
that pool yeah they got to see like
everything that's ever perished in the
pool is there yeah a bunch of coats
in the water a bunch of dead beans
a bunch of icky band-aids all sort of
rolled up into a humanoid figure
yeah
anything and everything you might find
in a pool
a candy bar that turns out to actually
just be poop there's a pool movie to be
made there's there's there's a franchise
there wasn't
a comic book character would the name
pool in it deadpool would have been a
good [ __ ] title
oh goodness
oh there's gotta be another deadpool
what deadpool three rebooted yes
marvel cinematic grittiest
uh is there a chlorine pun we could do
it's like some menacing title life on
guard
oxygen
hold your breath
yeah
breathe
water
wet
wet water wet water
the shallows
drowning the shallows and
the the drought to screw this guys up
gravity falls was great good episode uh
i'm gonna commit the next few hours now
to writing we'll have gravity falls up
for another few weeks
as i'm gonna be hard at work for the
next two months
plugging away at this screenplay trying
to sell it to netflix which is the pool
yeah
and then i'm going to start a gofundme
here yeah to get the pool movie if you
want to be one of the first backers if
you want a co-producer credit join up
now join up now become a pool become a
pool member become a member of our
public member of the pool please we'll
send you perks like uh some official
pool movie swim trunks get autographed
blu-rays when they're released we'll
post a blog every time we do something
to make the film happen you want
snorkeling devices we got it branded
goggles you want goggles we got goggles
you want that white stuff you put on
your nose we got it we got it you want
some sunscreen we got it
500 spf
spf maybe there's a there's
uh
some prefer
you know
yeah so soup some pool friend no
uh
slaughter pool
exclusively exploitative movies
exclusively z grade no budget what did
we have on hand on the back lot that no
one was using today movies
uh death pool the pool that eats there
it's called death pool death pool last
sounds just too much
yeah that's death
uh yeah was there a
call waterlogged
what
moist
the moistening the moistening the
moistening
the deep
the d the deep end the deep end
dependent deep end
dark water started jennifer what's your
name i don't like most titles i have the
word dark in and plus it's like the
darkness
typically yeah it's an easy way to go
word for darker that's the subject of
this horror movie it's about water how
about
dark water no one's gonna think that's a
comedy are they
ah let's do a picture of the day
this is easy
what were you thinking saying count
three one
two three
answer all right
tyler hey i shouted out tyler hang
already then lance door lance door
that's door
think about you drown in a pool who's
gonna resuscitate you dude lance is
gonna come in with his rippling pecs and
his bulging biceps he's gonna lift you
out and you're gonna be like pouring
water sunlight will be shining behind
him perfectly contouring each and every
curve of his muscular building that's
high in his occupation all right but
guess what you're also on fire as you
push out of the pool so what does he do
he whips that hose out hoses you have to
take
he gets the jaws of life out because
you're stuck in the vending machine you
tried to get something out with your
hand and you got your arm stuck so he's
got the jaws of life and he's cutting
the machine he's taking his ideas
straight out of my pool movie i'm sorry
okay lance dora uh he comforts you with
his professional demeanor as a
representative of the fire department
like here hold my axe yeah
[Music]
go scuba diving under there in fact let
me just drive the truck into the bed
that way back it up yeah you're gonna
get up
get out of the pool you just back up
lance you are the lifeguard that we all
deserve
and the one we need right now
[Music]